[Music]  Stephen Colbert is speaking out on the  backlash over his controversial Trump  bashing monologue he doesn't stand by  anything except the dressing room door  Miss USA pageant the 52 year old late  night host addressed the drama on  Wednesday's episode of The Late Show  revealing he hasn't lost sleep over his  jokes aimed at president Trump still am  I still the host I'm still the host I  don't regret that  I believe he can take care of himself I  have jokes he has the launch codes so  it's a fair fight the hashtag fire  Colbert started trending on Twitter this  week after the verbal assault but still  the comedians stance remains the same I  will do it again  [Music]